absent clyde edwards hilaire in his
debut in the nfl
25 carries 138 yards and a touchdown
he had no catches though we talked so
much about what he could do in the
passing game he was targeted twice with
zero catches
so it and it's by the way it's clyde
edwards
no h h is silent something we're all
learning now especially those of us that
did watch a whole lot of college
football last year played edward delaire
and uh he got it done and and that's
what the chiefs needed that was their
their gamble and uh here's a little
um reaction from uh last night to what
edward zeller did in his first game in
the nfl
he is he is a tough son of a buck uh
for for how tall he is man he's got the
strength of
of somebody my size man he runs the ball
like uh like like no one i've ever seen
at that size and it's uh it's fun
it's fun to play with man it's it's
infectious when you see him out there
playing his tail off he's a great
guy for us um i think he's gonna you
know continue to add to this offense
and give us that spark that we need um
you know i felt like he really showed up
today and
you know we played a balanced game you
know all the way around i think he was a
big part of that
he's going to keep getting better it's
another another weapon
i kind of i kind of have in this offense
and we're going to keep doing whatever
we can to keep moving the ball and
scoring touchdowns
um ultimately i'm now just trying to
just trying to take it all in still
doing interviews
still haven't got a chance to chase my
mom or you know he
like as far as take talk to any family
so
ultimately uh when i leave and head home
and that's i think it'll all
start to start to hit then but for the
most part i'm still on my
on my game feeling still feeling like i
could go out there and play
two more quarters i'm just i'm just kind
of just floating
you know and the thing about clyde
edward zelaire
and any you know i didn't i didn't quite
realize
how small he was going to look in
comparison to everyone else yeah and
and tony dungy made the point at
halftime that
uh he reminded uh edward zeller reminded
tony of work done
right and but but but he's a thicker
version of work done yeah he looks like
a guy who will be
better suited than work done was to make
those
those runs between the tackle on a
consistent basis and carry that load
without getting too banged up he's built
to to to be involved in what you call
the car crashes
definitely uh based on the first game
with no pre-season
with no joint practices with no chance
to go against an opponent
25 carries 138 yards number one it shows
the faith
that the chief's having him right out of
the gates and number two it shows the
production right out of the gates yeah
well the one thing i heard throughout
the draft process
the maturity of the players so i'm not
surprised that they trusted him in the
situation and all that
you know second of all yeah for a guy
that's short he's five eight
five seven whatever it is it's right
around that area i mean you saw his legs
you know i'm
i'm a leg looker his butt and legs have
got some serious power in them and
that's why
you know to what travis kelsey is saying
there's a few times where jj watt was on
his back hitting him and couldn't like
bring him to the
ground i mean it's it's unbelievable but
then you know
what we saw like on that touchdown run
that's where i think he's just so
special his ability to the vision
to see something put his foot in the
ground
stop let the defender go by
re-accelerate
he's not a guy that's going to go for
like 70 and 80 yard touchdowns but
other than that he has got it all and
his start restart ability acceleration
quickness put your foot in the ground is
elite for the nfl and that's where i
think he's going to make
this kansas city offense to a point
where yeah you're going to have to
reassess if andy's going to be patient
with the run like that
and they are continue to willing to have
this
underneath attack you know it's not
gonna let teams just sit back and play
let's bend and don't break
because you're just gonna bend and then
you're gonna break they're too good
they're too smart mahomes is too smart
and uh
and honestly last night i'll tell you
what else mike i know we text about this
the way the texans defense played it
took their offense out of the game
i mean they never gotten a rhythm you
know they got some cheap yards and
points at the end of the game when it
was over but i do think it affected them
on that side of the ball too
which we talked about you know with
other teams before hey
if you're going to play through desean
watson and four receivers and be high
flying
what the hell's the point of having all
those guys they're gonna be sitting over
there by the gatorade bottles the whole
game
well and and it's it's a testament to
the chief's ability to react to
adversity and maybe that's one of the
great lessons they learned last year
when you're down double digits
plus in the game against the texans well
it's still double digits not triple
digits but it's 24
to the texans 10 to the titans 10 to the
49ers you fall behind
seven nothing in the first game of the
season that's when you flip the switch
to the ultra methodical approach because
they had that first drive
where they went down the field and the
touchdown catch looked good
and after an extended replay that made
the first quarter take a hell of a lot
longer than it should have
the touchdown was taken off the board
there was the mahomes sack the drive
sputtered out the texans score
and that's when the chief slipped right
into
we'll just take what you give us and
think of how disheartening that is
especially without with edward zeller
averaging 5.5 yards per carry
you are on your heels ready for the
patrick mahomes onslaught
and they run it right up the middle and
they gain four or five yards
and you're ready for the onslaught and
they run it right up the middle and they
gain four or five yards
and if you ever dare to adjust to that
that's when they're going to get you for
a 50-yarder and it's it's an ultimate
pick your poison type of an approach
that they're crafting
and it's not going to be easy for the
upcoming opponents to figure out how to
deal with it no it's not you're gonna
you're gonna have to have a special
defense i mean
that's really what it's gonna going to
come down to you know i mean
listen i know this is something we've
talked about that's what's scary about
the chiefs the chiefs i don't even think
played their best football last year
you know i don't think they were as good
as they last years they were two years
ago really consistently throughout the
regular season
but it just shows you what they can be
get hot in a moment whatever else
and they become unstoppable and with
this variety of weapons
on the offensive side of the ball
accompanied with andy reid and what
he'll do with eric b enemy and being
aggressive on the offensive side of ball
now the run game
you're right i mean we talk about good
offenses make you defend every square
inch of the field i think kansas city's
taking that to like another level
and it's gonna take the baltimore's
and the 49ers of the world and probably
the patriots teams that got
a lot enough guys in the secondary to go
okay
we can take some chances up front
because we have high level corners that
we're willing to put on an island with
these freaky wide receivers in kansas
city from time to time
but other than that i just have a hard
time thinking yeah the middle of the
road defenses in the nfl can ever keep
pace with this chiefs team
i think it's more important to have a
defensive line that can shut down the
run than can get after mahomes because
we know that you can't
ultimately get mahomes from time to time
you're going to get lucky and it was
weird to see him get sacked yeah it was
right
for the most part he's going to squirt
away and he's going to go make something
happen
and if you can just shut down the
running game and force them to be one
dimensional i think that's going to be
the key to have any chance against the
chiefs force them to be one dimensional
against the pass
and hope that you can shut them down
they did a good job with tyree kill last
night
doubled in most of the game he only had
five catches for 46 yards
one touchdown late spread the touchdowns
around three of them one to hill one to
travis kelsey one to sammy watkins
sammy watkins benefits the extra
attention paid to tyree kill seven
catches 82 yards
it shows you why they found a way to
work out a contract with sammy watkins
it would keep him around
because otherwise you got to thrust
someone else into that role of the
beneficiary of tyreek hill being doubled
yeah
exactly he's you know and i think you
see last night when sammy watkins is
healthy he's special
you know like we saw in the super bowl
when he ran by richard sherman
you know his ability to catch the ball
and then just
explode up field to where okay he caught
the ball at eight or nine yards
but how many times did he do that and
then within two steps
he's up field and he's kind of getting
tackled with people around him but he
got an
extra seven eight yards where you go oh
you got 15 yards caught the ball at
eight i mean uh unreal that way
and you're right he'll continue to be
the beneficiary of what you have to do
because tyreek hill
is you know one of the fastest guys on
the planet
you gotta have extra attention on him
there's really
maybe one or two corners in football
that you're going to be able to trust
with him
regularly regularly throughout the game
i can't say that word
so the texans don't have one of them so
they had to protect them
and then therefore that makes kansas
city even tougher and it's why they're
so fun to watch it really is because
this talent and everything about it is
just uh it's kind of can't miss tv
admitting you can't say the word does
not make it
regular regularly
regularly regularly i i would understand
if it was something like onomatopoeia or
something like that but it's regularly i
don't know it's not coming out of my
mouth
relax it doesn't even have a till day in
it all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports